تواصل الشائعات وتتواصل لملاحقه الفنان
المغربي سعد المجرد وهو كما تعرفون يمضي
عقوبه بالسجن في احد سجون فرنسا اخر هذه
الاشاعات ادعتن الفنانه الشهير اقدم على
الانتحار والسبب المزعوم هو الاكتئاب
الحاد لكن الخبر عار عن الصحه موقع هسبريس
المغربي جزم من مصادره بان الخبر غير صحيح
مع العلم ان المجرد يقبع داخل احد سجون
باريس مداواخر شهر فبراير الماضي وذلك بعد
ان دانته محكمه فرنسيه بتهمه اغتصاب فتاه
المحكمه حكمت على المجرد بالسجن ست سنوات
فيما تعود للقضيه الى اكتوبر 2016
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات